Speaker 1: There is a new book coming out from
Donald Trump's former secretary of defense,
Mark Esper. In the book, Esper says that Donald
Trump wanted to have Black Lives Matter protesters
shot. Where do we start? Axios reporting scoop.
Esper Says Trump Wanted To Shoot Protesters. This
is from Mike Allen. Mike Allen, a long history
of very important scoops. The book is called The
Sacred Oath. Former Defense Secretary Mark
Esper charges in a memoir out May ten that
former President Trump said when demonstrators
were filling the streets around the White House
after the death of George Floyd, quote, Can't you
just shoot them? Just shoot them in the legs or
something? The book is Sacred Oath contains vivid
first person revelations by a top cabinet member,
bolstering outsider accounts of extreme
dysfunction in the Trump White House. Esper
was fired by Trump after the 2020 election. That
moment in the first week of June 2020 was surreal,
sitting in front of the Resolute desk inside
the Oval Office with this idea weighing heavily
in the air and the president red faced and
complaining loudly about protests in D.C..
Esper goes on to say the good news this wasn't
a difficult decision, not shooting protesters.
The bad news, I had to figure out a way to
walk Trump back without creating the mess
I was trying to avoid. This book was vetted at
the highest levels of the Pentagon. Some of the
of the four star generals who vetted the book
or reviewed it witnessed what Esper witnessed.
I mean, listen, there's a few different things
here. First of all, shoot people for their speech.
I thought they were for free speech for all
of the First Amendment stuff they claim to
be all about Trump saying, well, what about
shooting people, exercising free speech rights?
I want to go into a different direction with
this, though. I find it almost traitorous
that many of these former Trump administration
officials wait sometimes years to tell us about
this stuff until they can monetize it. I would
argue that it was Mark Esper's duty to go public
with this when it was happening. If a president
wants to shoot protesters for protesting, then
it is almost as outrageous to stay quiet about it
until you can make money from it in a book. I get
why they do it. They all do it. It's not unique to
Mark Esper, but it is fundamentally not loyalty to
what is best for the country. It is a loyalty to
what is best for his wallet. And I get it. I know
why they are doing it. But this is so extreme
and so outrageous that you could make the case
that it borders on treason not to immediately blow
the whistle publicly on something like this. Now.
Let's be as charitable as possible. Is it possible
that Mitch McConnell and the RNC told Esper to
sit on this stuff? Let's see how far the January
6th committee goes. Let's let's wait before you.
It's possible, but there's no evidence of
that, and it doesn't seem particularly likely.
I disagree with conservatism, but this idea.
Shoot protesters. It's not conservatism. I'm
not praising conservatism. And I
disagree with conservatism. But
this is not conservatism. These ideas are neo
reactionary authoritarianism and it's Republicans
sort of resorting to the absolute worst human
traits. And some of them seem to lack the
intellectual capacity to turn these things
into reality. Trump thought about shooting
protesters. He didn't do it. His secretary of
defense wasn't willing to do it as far as he
claims. I guess Trump just wasn't able to make it
a reality. A less incompetent person at the helm
might actually be able to get some of this stuff
to become a reality. And that's why the idea of
what about the Santas are less incompetent but
just as dangerous version of Trump as a possible
Republican nominee. That's why it's so dangerous
and horrifying. So that's the latest from Esper.
I don't plan on buying the book. I don't
read any of these types of books. I've got
too much other stuff to read that I find more
interesting, but not a revelation that I would
doubt. It is in line with everything we've seen
from Donald Trump. But Esper should have gone
public earlier. With this, we'll have more on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman show